let's talk about being Mary Jane people
love this show very popular you get to
be very sexual on the show
yeah I'm just curious how does that go
over with your family I just think that
because I come from like kind of
Catholic people and so when I'm in a
very sexy movie which ok that does that
it now she doesn't work but anyway yeah
I could see them getting upset what
about your my mom our family is Catholic
as well and my mom teaches catechism
like she is a CCD teacher she is at one
with the Lord didn't Savior Jesus Christ
and so when she sees that you know like
I have a parade of penises on my show
that's kind of like what this show is
about you mean an actual part like there
are marching
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
they're playing the national anthem we
have a salute good god she's just she's
mortified and she's thinking like I know
we didn't take a second out on the house
to send you to UCLA for all these
penises to be on your show yeah exactly
it's exactly what happens when you don't
do well on the SAT
[Laughter]
you